[Music]
hello YouTube chess Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my 57th
episode of dirty chance tricks in this
episode I am going to show you a tricky
and aggressive line and in fact a mini
recruit ah against peer defense from the
white perspective the opening is also
named as mad dog attack as you will see
that white is willing to sacrifice even
Queen further attack the opening arises
after the following model
efore d6 d4 Knight to f6 Knight to c3
defending on e4 and now the
characteristic rear defense move g6 so
planning is very simple black wants to
play Bishop to g7 castle and then later
on head back in the center and against
this White has tried various responses
but we are going to see one of the most
aggressive one which start with Bishop
to c4 and after the move Bishop to g7
white plays his queen on e to square now
this position has been reached many
times in official video games and here
black has tried various responses but if
you check the online database you will
find out that Knight to c6 has been
tried highest Lee and it is logical as
well as White has weakened the d4 pawn
why not to play Knight to c6 and attack
that weak spot
if you have seen this position first
time you might think what has to
safeguard the default pawn right well
guess what mad dog doesn't have brain
and the only thing they know is bite the
enemy very quickly and accordingly ePHI
as a fitting reply
now the main line move here is Knight
captures d4 but before we look at it
black has also tried other two Knight
moves so let's see what we are going to
do about it the first move I want to
consider is Knight to d7 which is in
fact a passive choice by black and
against this if you want a solid game
you can play the move Knight to f3 and I
have attached a model line in the PGN
however in the spirit of mad dog attack
my suggestion here is you should play
this aggressive piece sacrifice Bishop
captures f7 BAM the point is when black
take our piece we are going to get our
piece back with the moon Essex and by
sacrificing this pawn what we achieve is
black king is permanently stuck at the
center of the board here white can
continue with Knight to f3 and it
doesn't matter whether black continue
with Bishop to g4 all night captors d4
both gives white a very aggressive set
up so if black plays Bishop g4 we can
continue with Queen to e4 attacking the
bishop and after Bishop takes Queen
takes black can't get his extra pawn
with Knight captures d4 but after Queen
to d3 I think black has a use problem
due to the simple fact that his King is
going to permanently remain in the
center and for a pawn this is a great
compensation as white attack commands
quickly with Bishop to e3
well same goes if black captured the
bond immediately as after Knight
captures d4 you can simply capture this
night and after Bishop takes and the
move Queen to see for once the bishop
retrieve weekend castle on the Kings
side and as I have highlighted over here
the simple but effective plan of
campaign and in all this lines because
black king is stuck in the center white
has very good attacking prospects in
upcoming middle game the second more I
want to consider is Knight to g4 which
is in fact played in roughly 150 games
and against this my recommendation is
you should continue with Bishop to b5
setting up a nice trap well the main
line start with castle on the Kings side
but if your opponent is not familiar
with this territory then he might take
on ePHI thinking that yes I can win the
pawn and yes indeed at first sight this
looks completely safe for the black camp
except one problem there White has this
winning move defy and by force we are
winning the piece how can't black
counter-attack with the movie 6 well he
can but after the following forcing
sequence pawn takes c6 a captures be
fire and finally C captures b7 which
deflect the guardian of this g4 night
and at the end of the sequence indeed
white emerge with an extra piece so D
captures Aoife is right out of the
equation that means black has to castle
on the Kings side and after the edge
first of all we are going to capture on
c6
and then keep this night with the moon
h3 and once the night goes to the very
poor square we can continue with night
to have three completing of a piece
level of mind so you can see by the end
of the sequence black get some horrible
pawn structure on the Queen side and the
only way to get rid of this double pawn
is to place ePHI immediately
counter-attacking the white center but
here comes GJ chess novelty as all the
games continue with decap to c5 and I
have a touch of sample line in the PGA
in case if you don't like my
recommendation but I'm going to propose
a new marine disposition which has been
never played and that is Queen to Evo
the good thing I like about this line is
it stopped Bishop to b7 idea which is
the main trump card in black position
after rook to b8 we are going to capture
on c5 and now you can see Bishop to b7
is not possible due to the c6 so obvious
response is Bishop to e6 stopping white
to castle on the Queen side but in mix
of others what black has forget is White
has won an important pawn and after the
move c6 I think and gene conforms
advantage the best line can goes as
follows
Asics trying to get defy in so naturally
white responses force why it has to play
Bishop to g5 and once the Queen moon the
amazing but beautiful New Castle on the
Queen side and now you can see the
importance of c6 pawn it completely
blocked black attack one Queen side a
sample accurate moves can goes like this
defy
but what will keep supporting with Queen
to e4 not only defending but attacking
the bishop and after rook to b6 and the
moon knight to d4 I think we should stop
here as White has consolidated his extra
material as well as his species are very
nicely placed and you can analyze by
yourself and going to the deft
especially if we want to include this
line in the tournament recruit are just
for your knowledge engine gives one
percent advantage to the white game
which is literally of winning one
finally let's see what is going to
happen after the obvious move Knight
captures d4 and attacking of a queen
well again here you can play Bishop f7
and that's an alternative you can check
out in the PGN however I like this Queen
sacrifice line which goes as follow he
captures f6 Knight captures e2e captures
g7 and after rook to g8 and Knight G
captures e - yes indeed
white obtained three minor piece for
Queen and a to pawn which is generally
not a good trade but not in this
position as after Bishop takes rook to
g8 and now castle on the Queen side you
can see every single white piece is in
the attack and look at black how every
single one of them are sitting at the
back benches hasn't that wonderful when
I was preparing this video I have done
some heavy research and the most
interesting part I found about this line
is there are hundred and twenty-two
games played in the database from this
position and amongst them the results
are very shocking 22 draws hell only 28
loss that means 72
wind by wide which is a quite a heavy
margin so practical point of view this
is a great position to play as a white
player now there are no clear theory so
I like to show you a model game which
will give you a very good idea how
quickly white can rip apart black if
black doesn't play accurately this is a
game between two strong GM where black
continue with ethics and naturally white
respond with h4 and the idea is very
simple one to play h5 and liberate the H
rook ok black plays Queen to f6 and as
soon as the Queen comes out white target
the Queen wait Knight to e4 and when
black counter-attack with Queen to e5
white safely negotiate with Knight to c3
setting up a cunning trick which black
stayed away falling to it well who can
resist the move defy as you are winning
the piece on the spot but there is a big
problem and the problem can be
highlighted with the following model
Bishop captures defy pawn captures defy
and now Knight captures defy and
suddenly black and see the danger clouds
are moving towards his King as there are
multiple threats here number one Knight
to f6 number 2
Bishop to f4 and Knight captures c7
obviously after a long thought black
find out nothing better than
counter-attack with f5 but now white
game become very easy Knight to f6 Jack
King to f7 and now the star mu doesn't
even bother about capturing the rook get
you're all big boys in the party rook to
even
and I'm afraid plaque is completely
busted Quinn can't move as rook to e7 is
a checkmate if you try to defend with d6
then it is not going to help as after
Knight captures g8 you lost an important
piece as you can't recapture due to the
knight a 7 check and the natural move
Bishop to e6 completely fails due to the
simple tactics Knight to f4 and black
and literally back his back and go home
well in the game black find nothing
better than capturing on even but after
rook takes even the rook is 7 checkmate
is on the card so black has to defend it
first but then the task become very easy
yup you guessed it nightcap to c7
attacking the second room and when that
rook moves we can simply laugh up one of
the rook in the corner and that night on
g8 is still immune so black finally
decided to capture on c7 and at first
sight it looks like when black get the
piece back he have at least chance of
the draw but guess what that night is
coming out in a style before I'm on I
like you to pause this video and find
out how you are going to evacuate that
night
did you find it
let's see the Faust mo is very obvious
Square vacation fit fish up to a four
and when black rook moves we can deliver
this check but still it looks like
Knight has no future to come out right
well here comes the master plan and that
is f3 chief Oh
sooner or later the Evergreen freedom
will be on the card
well the game finished very quickly
black tried the last desperate attempt
Luke to c4 but after Bishop to g5 Jack
King to d7 and now the finishing blow
Knight to f7 and suddenly Knight Springs
out with a wonderful gesture the point
is you can take this night as after rook
to e7 check King to d6 and rook F step 7
white is a whole piece of and not a
single pond down
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful mad dog attack
against the peer defense remember if you
open and capture on d4 take the knight
on f6 sacrifice your queen because this
sequence only leads to the advantageous
position to the white cam and no matter
however black wriggles the result shows
that it is only white who is bossing the
game thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care